[Music]
well it was just three days ago that
Kathy Griffin was apologizing for Posey
with the bloody severed head of the
president but look at her now fighting
back well nobody saw this coming I was
there this morning as Kathy lawyered up
and melted dead I've had everybody turn
on me and I just want to make people
laugh that's all I want to do so I
screwed up tearing up at times the
comedian revealed the outcry from her
photo shoot has caused her to fear for
her life the death threats that I'm
getting are constant and they are
detailed and they're serious in their
specific so regarding the image that I
participated in the apology absolutely
stands I feel horrible she called the
press conference to say that she is
being bullied by the Trump family
through their comments and social media
tweets a sitting president of the United
States and his grown children and the
first lady are personally I feel
personally trying to ruin my life
forever
et contacted the White House for a
comment on Griffin's allegations we did
not hear back by our deadline Griffin
says she will not be silenced I'm gonna
make fun of the president and you know
what I'm gonna make fun of him more now
war so I'm not going to threaten him I
have no desire to harm him or anyone I
would never want to harm anybody Griffin
is hired attorney Lisa bloom but made no
announcement of a lawsuit
I asked Kathy about her firing from CNN
New Year's Eve hosting job with Anderson
Cooper have you had a chance to talk to
Anderson
yeah admitting she made a mistake Kathy
was at times defiant wanting to take on
the White House
so yeah I'm obnoxious comedian I'm not
the most famous person in the world and
this bully and this president of all
people is gonna come after me he picked
the wrong redhead those are strong words
but the consensus on social media seems
to be that people are not rallying to
Cathy side
[Music]
you